part of the premise of the the books and
the television series is the fact that
there are the
these entirely unpredictable seasons uh
and obviously it clearly matters to
everybody economically politically and
just in terms of survival knowing when
winter's coming
winter is coming
it is not
it's not so yes another variable in
duration so the seasons they're
unpredictable when they'll come and how
long they're going to last for is
completely unpredictable
there are two aspects to it the main
aspect to seasons on our planet is to do
with the tilt of the earth axis and when
the earth's axis is tilted towards the
sun in the hemisphere you happen to be
whether that's north or south then
you're in summer and obviously as the
earth goes around the sun one part of
the year you're leaning towards the sun
you have summer part of the year you're
leaning away from the sun then you have
winter that's the main aspect then
there's a slight secondary aspect which
is that the earth's orbit is not exactly
circular and when the earth is uh is
closer to the sun it's a little bit
warmer when it's further away it's a
little bit colder and that actually the
point when you're closest to the sun
actually occurs in january
um and that's why summers in the
southern hemisphere which obviously are
in full swing in january are a little
warmer than summers in the northern
hemisphere so on westeros on the planet
where westeros is you have these
entirely unpredictable seasons which
means it must be something much more
complicated is going on and obviously
you know we're talking about a fictional
world here so if you want it can just be
magic but it would be nice to try and
figure out if there can actually be some
sort of scientific explanation as to
what's going on
you know nothing
geographically
if you have features on your planet they
can actually have a strong impact on the
climate of the planet for example
um you could have some fairly narrow
seaway through which some important
stream of warm water was traveling which
was keeping your planet reasonably warm
and so then if that fairly narrow
passageway froze up that would then cut
off the supply of warm water and then
you get into this kind of positive
feedback thing and actually that's a
very common feature of these chaotic
systems it can be a long time before it
could then
thaws out again and you can start the
next summer season so another
terrestrial thing that could be
responsible for it is if you had
periodic volcanic eruptions because we
know that actually volcanoes on the
earth when they throw large amounts of
dust into the atmosphere that can
actually have an effect on the
temperature and so you could imagine a
rather strange planet in which the
seasons were dictated by whether or not
there had been a recent volcanic
eruption
that once there were two moons in the
sky
but one wandered too close to the sun
and it cracked
okay so moving on to possible
astronomical explanations as i said the
tilt of the of the axis of a planet is
at least in the case of the earth i
think that's responsible for the the the
seasons and you could imagine if that
tilt were actually wobbling around a
place then that would mean that the
seasons would change in a really rather
strange and unpredictable kind of way
and in fact when we study the the angles
at which the axes of the planets in the
solar system are oriented they do
actually vary over time the earth
famously does but actually all the other
planets do as well and they actually do
it in this chaotic way they actually
move around in a way which is very hard
to predict and so you could imagine that
seasons are being driven by a planet in
which that axis is tilting around very
rapidly the reason why this probably
doesn't work is that if you think about
it you've got this spinning planet what
you've got to do is reorient that entire
spin so you've actually changed from a
spin planet spinning like this to a
planet that's spinning over like that
that's a huge amount of angular momentum
you've got to get shifted somewhere so
it has to be some interaction with some
other body in the in the stellar system
in which this thing lives the planetary
system in which it lives and
transferring that amount of angular
momentum and we have to do this on a
time scale of just a few years because
we want the winters to be lasting a year
or two years or 10 years so those kind
of time scales it probably doesn't work
but at least in theory that's a way of
getting seasons to change in a rather
unpredictable way there's great honor
serving in the night's watch starks have
manned the wall for thousands of years
if you have a very elliptical orbit
indeed when the thing's close to the
star it's orbiting it'll be nice and
warm and then when it goes away it'll
get very cold but the trouble with that
is that that's entirely predictable
because i think orbits around you know
once per year the years lengths don't
change kepler's laws keep it going
around on a nice elliptical orbit so if
that were all that was going on you
wouldn't have you might have seasons
which were dictated by the distance but
actually those seasons wouldn't move
around they wouldn't vary in length from
one year to the next
so what you need to do is come up with
some way of messing with the orbit
making it so it's not just a normal
ellipse and the way you do that well we
get an ellipse when you have a planet
that's going around one star but if you
had a binary star two stars and you've
got a planet in orbit around it then the
orbits get much more complicated and you
can have again you can have chaos
setting in and you can have the the
average distance between that particular
planet and the stars will vary over time
in a really rather complicated way and
again that can lead to very
unpredictable seasons professor you get
the feeling that if
there were two suns blazing over
westeros it would have come up in the
books at some point you would think it
would get a mention somewhere along the
line which means that probably if there
is a second star it has to be very faint
and then because then you would probably
only reference the big star in the sky
your sun
and if you had a second object it could
be a white dwarf star or maybe even a
neutron star or one of these things
called a brown dwarf which wasn't quite
massive enough to form you know start
the nuclear fusion processes and really
become a bright star itself then perhaps
that's what's going on and so they don't
bother to mention it in the books
because it's there but it's just not
that worthy of mention it's not the
thing that keeps you warm
my dreams are different mine are true
one of the ways that's completely
different from here on earth of making
seasons vary making the average
temperature of your your planet vary is
by making the brightness of the star
that you're orbiting around very with
time and again one of the nice things
about this is that there are indeed
variable stars out there and actually
some of these variable stars do indeed
display this phenomenon of chaos that
some of them vary in a very predictable
way but some of them vary really in
completely unpredictable ways and so
that could be a very nice way of making
seasons be completely unpredictable that
sometimes your star gets a little bit
brighter and that warms everything up
sometimes it gets a little bit fainter
and that cools everything down
and that would sort of meet the bill
rather nicely because it is completely
unpredictable it hasn't introduced any
new physics along the way and it's a way
of actually making the seasons sort of
come and go in a way that you really
wouldn't be able to predict ahead of
time
there's a longer version of this
interview with professor merefield also
online that includes more about how
planets move around binary stars
more about variable stars an academic
paper written about game of thrones
astronomy and also a little bit about
the tv shows opening sequence and things
called dyson spheres so check that out
it's on our astronomy channel deep sky
videos i'll have a link on the screen
link in the video description
and if you haven't heard of deep sky
videos well that's another channel you
should have subscribed to by now